hello everyone in the yes it's me again
a story about all the notifications but
what can I do all the games are
incredibly interesting so we are at the
game 4 of the Magnus Invitational match
between Nakamura and Carlson Carlson
leading 2 to 1 and Nakamura needs to win
on demand now Crossman was able to win
both of his games with the white pieces
in the exact same line and Nakamura of
course we won the game where where
Carson went for the are congas in the
rule opus so here for the 4th game
Nakamura sticks that efore but across
and already deviates and he goes for c5
the Sicilian and okay we have Knight to
f3 with East 6d for C captures and e4
Knight captures and Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 Magnus was for d6
with Bishop to e3 and Bishop e7
basically this haven in the variation of
the Sicilian and f4 by Nakamura this is
all very standard Knight to c6 and now
Queen to f3 preparing to Castle
queenside and here we have e 5 most
popular move for black we have Knight
captures the B captures and here f5 is
the move that is most often played here
but Nakamura goes for the very very rare
Bishop to c4 he has the trick cousin
somehow and Magnus decides that before
castling he's just gonna shift his
knight over to g4 it makes sense as it
comes with an attack on the bishop of
course Nakamura doesn't want to give up
the dark square bishop so we have a
bishop to d2 and now again before
casting first captures on f4 clearing
the e5 square for the knight and the
night will be very very much needed
there as you'll see so Bishop captures
now Magnus castles Nakamura decides to
Castle kingside instead not to go for a
queenside castle and Bishop to f6 now
and although Nakamura has the semi-open
F file with a lot of pressure here
towards the f7 pawn Magnus says that
it's not an issue as he already has his
knight and nicely placed here and once
he shifts him over to e5 that's all he
needs
and there is one game in the database
for King's the h1 was played but here we
have Bishop to b3 and it is as a move 14
that we have
completely new game so like I said
magnets not really worried about the df7
weakness
so he goes rook to e8 and now rook a to
be one with ideas so maybe pushing a
five at some point so just Knight to e5
and that's the idea behind that nice the
g4 maneuver just shifting it over to e5
Queen to g3 and now comes at Bishop to
a6 attacking Nakamura's rook here and
this is where our well the game started
long before but this is where the fun
part starts here instead of moving the
rook nakamora plays Bishop captures on
e5 and okay here we have Bishop captures
on e5 or you can go for Bishop captures
on f1 but then you get Bishop captures
and f6 threatening checkmate
and once Queen captures you're gonna get
rook captures and f1 and White has two
pieces for the rook which is of course
much better and there's still all this
pressure towards the f7 form so it would
be a winning position for white so
instead after Bishop captures on e5
cross and recaptures attacks the
Nakamura's queen we have Bishop captures
on f7 with check King to h8 and now as
your queen is still under attack feel
free to pause the video and once again a
fine nakamora Smoove while i give you a
couple of seconds so once again
congratulations for to everyone who
knows is that this is position the
position from the thumbnail and again we
have a sufficient souk a nice in-between
move as the title would suggest and here
before deciding what to do with the
Queen Bishop capture Sonny eight point
being that now if you go for the Queen
Nakamura has a rook to f8 checkmate as
the mushroom blocks of course the
Queen's well
path to the f8 square so this this
obviously rattled Magnus a little bit
because here you have to go for Bishop
captures on f1 and only after rook
captures now you remove it with Queen to
b6 checking each one and now you pick up
the bishop with rook captures here now
white moves the Queen ended the game
continues while nakamora would still be
threatening mate so you'd have to go for
something like a g6 and so on the game
continues however Magnus went for Queen
to b6 check right away but
Nakamura blocks with the Queen of course
you can't leave the Queen hanging and
now comes Luke captures on e8 again
Bishop captures an f1 is the correct way
to go you have to grab that rook
otherwise you're just gonna be down the
exchange but that's exactly what Magnus
did he played rook captures any eight
and now Nakamura just grabbed the Queen
Queen captures pawn captures and now he
just moved the rook rook to f7 and after
all is said and done and Nakamura is AB
B exchange so k h6 by Magnus and now
rook the c7 just going after those juicy
pawns
we have c5 and now look the c6 going
after this pawn and here it's incredibly
hard to play and especially Magnus was a
very sad that he missed such a tactic
and well here he just III don't think he
even cared about the game all that much
better up to be for checking h1 he
captured on c3 to grab the e4 pawn as
well but the Nakamura just continues
happily gobbling up pawn to rook
character son b6 with Bishop to c4 and
if you could somehow get for example to
the g2 pawn maybe you could still do
something but Nakamura just starts
pushing his past a pawn we have rook to
eat you but now just rook be cactus and
e6 rook captures and c2 n now of course
rook to a1 Nakamura puts the rogue
behind the passed pawn cross and grabbed
the c3 pawn and now just a 5 and it was
in this position that Magnus Carlsen
resigned the game and incredible
nakamura wins undermanned
so really incredible stuff out of four
games all for decisive games both both
Hikaru and Magnus winning with white
white pieces both times and now of
course they go into Armageddon so stay
tuned we're gonna check that out as well
and really really the crazy stuff Magnus
really outmaneuvered Hikaru were in the
games that where Magnus was white but
the camera really crushed calls and in
the games that he was white first that
nice checkmate on e5 and then well just
this again with the beautiful tuition
soup so very good stuff so we're gonna
cover the Armageddon game and then we
are on to covering Alireza vs ding but I
will most likely do those tomorrow
before we start around to do well around
one day to basically so once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Pierre Asaf underestimate koloski
Dominic Robson and Taronga Tantra and
kyun paya for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day